[Musique]
sourire lumineux enthousiasme contagieux
Peggy attire les projecteurs même au
milieu des plus grandes vedettes du
baseball
taïwanaise de claques déborde d'énergie
sur la scène au grand plaisir de ses
fans ils sont plus de 300.000 la suivre
PEGI sur Facebook et Instagram
il participe à ses activités
commerciales
ils sont plus attentifs ou produits dont
elle fait la promotion sur ses réseaux
sociaux
les micros influenceurs comme Peggy
peuvent interagir avec leurs abonnés
dont le nombre ne dépasse pas quelques
centaines de milliers
ces micros influenceurs sont les plus
prisés en Asie le recommandation sont
perçus comme étant plus crédible et
moins trompeuses encore plus à Taïwan ou
les internautes sont habitués à se
méfier des fausses informations le
marché mondial des influenceurs voudrais
dépasser les 22 milliards de dollars
dans deux ans tirés à la hausse par
l'Asie berceau de Tik Tok et plus grand
marché de l'Internet mobile au monde non
Indiana
développer une présence et une influence
en ligne explique ce pionnier des
réseaux sociaux à Taïwan
les prix what Bell John pour les
productions web à Taïwan il souhaite
entre autres lutter contre la publicité
trompeuse le côté sombre des
influenceurs surtout à Taïwan bombardé
chaque jour par la désinformation
provenant de Chine
municipal depuis 4 ans il comptait
éduquer la population sur les réseaux
sociaux à la réalité politique de Taïwan
aussi veut promouvoir ce qui lui tient à
cœur
essaie de se différencier par son propre
créneau Peggy a choisi l'authenticité et
c'est Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada